هل توجهون نداء في هذه اللحظات الصعبه
وانتم تعيشون هذا الوضع وانت واحد من
الفريق الطبي داخل هذا المستشفى اي نداء
توجه ندائنا وتوجهنا لله عز وجل العالم
اخرس واطرش واعمى عما يحدث منذ اكثر من 35
يوم في مجمع الشفاء وفي قطاع غزه لا نتوجه
ولا ندعو الا الله ان يفرج عن غزه كربها
وان يشفي مصابينا ويرحم جرحانا ويضحى
الاحتلال لا نناشد اي احد للاسف تخلى عنا
الاخ والقريب قبل الغريب للاسف لم نشاهد
اي من الدول العربيه ل كنا ندعي انها
شقيقه او الدول الاوروبيه او مرك او مراكز
الامن او اي جهه تدخلت لايقاف هذا بحر
الدم النازف من غزه طالت الان القذائف
المستشفيات والمراكز المدنيه الانسانيه لا
نناشد اي احد حالنا لا يخفى على العالم
شاشتكم مشكوره جدا تعرض حالنا وتعرض
احوالنا على مدار الحرب الغاشمه على
غزه